vous trouvez votre binôme allez-y daniel
l'info avec qui avez-vous joué
daniel moreau et isabelle elle est
bannie voilà avec l'exode elle daniel
alors à la malaisie a essayé mais la
tolérance
donc allez-y vous tracasse pas d'autres
le nôtre alors je sais quoi alors mais
qu'est ce tu fais vous êtes sûr que
c'est pas dangereux mais impossibles
boussois
c'est quoi donc toi toi tu es là donc
toi tu es là mon avis toi tu es là tu as
l attention s'il vous plaît guillaume
surtout attention ici la chance d'être
tout sauf casse tête mais attention
merci les gars merci papa merci les gars
attention je me mets totalement donné
c'est mieux non sur le principe à niveau
leur home again
bon bah
[Musique]
pas mal de temps attention attention
cette fois nous mettez vous bien
attention c'est bien là j'aime bien très
bien ici well allait très bien mettait
le palet tu voulais battre le palais
voulait déjà dépasse là bas allez dans
l'est je rends tu sens que tu chantais
pas chaud là dessus les images sont tout
d'abord c'est parti ponelle boulba
bougez vous le cul allez savoir avec qui
vous êtes nicolas léger lui bientôt
aller 10 cette année
[Applaudissements]
les mecs j'ai cholet et on va le faire
en une fois je crois ça pour l'instant
ces kilos médecine qui gagne botha
technique au moyen d'un beau la vie
je ne sens pas mais nous en parlons
[Musique]
image maniaco exceptionnel ah bravo
attention et de garder ce qui reste
quasi officiel jean michel a donc je
pousserai qu'il y n'y a pas de triche
aucun n'a aucune prétention j'ai
attention j'ai pas une chance nicolas
mais vous avez su allez gillou il a tout
des non cadres
mais tu écris en place celle un garde
attention merci les gars merci et
durable interne à mon match et rivières
si les gars merci
alors attention les passions je pense
n'est pas grave erreur qu'ils
viendraient à détenir qu'ils veulent a
dit pas vu la bonne méthode si c'était
pas la bonne méthode
m j'avoue attention à nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vais décider les deux qui passeront
la soirée en sac plus belle
vous vous doutez bien ça n'est pas
isabelle ni l'adn ça n'est pas delphine
dit guillaume
ça n'est pas cité avec qui nicolas à moi
j'étais le deuxième là il m'a jamais
ouais ben jama et vous vous étiez qui
les bateaux stratégie de janvier
[Applaudissements]